why hello there do you like camping even
though you own a perfectly good home
do you like building things that you
could easily buy for a few dollars
do you prefer sleeping in a lean to even
though you just bought your fourth tent
if you like doing unnecessarily
complicated things because they're
freaking awesome then you're gonna love
this video buckle up buttercup cause I'm
Luke Nichols of the outdoor boys and I'm
gonna blow your mind
so do you want to make a drinking mug
more manly than punching a kangaroo in
the face
yeah you do first thing you're gonna
need is a cow horn
luckily I keep a box of them in my
garage
so we're gonna hit it with the heat gun
but if you don't have one of these you
can be daring and try a flame
foreign
[Applause]
just hold it till it cools
[Applause]
[Music]
now this mug is ready to use as is but
it will drip a little bit from the
bottom so I'm going to take some food
grade epoxy and just coat the bottom to
seal it up nicely
quick little hits with the blowtorch
make the bubbles go away it makes the
epoxy turn clear there we go our cowhorn
mug is done the epoxy's dried and it's
time to test it out on the manliest
drink I can imagine a low cow naturally
flavored seltzer water
it's watertight and guilt-free
this resin is really useful for a lot of
projects some of you guys may recognize
my cutting board that I use in some of
my campfire cooking videos this is just
a piece of aromatic Cedar that I coated
in this exact same food grade resin
after almost four years of use it's got
a lot of cut marks in it and I'm going
to go ahead and sand this down and then
apply another coat of this food grade
resin on it
foreign
there we go after the epoxy dried The
Cutting Board looks absolutely brand new
customized camping cutting board super
easy
you know what's manlier than shaving
your beard with a bearded ax turning a
four dollar Hatchet into your very own
bushcrafting tool there's few things
more manly and cool than making your own
Camp ax unfortunately forging went from
scratch requires a bit of specialty
tools and skills so a great alternative
is to restore your own ax I found this
one on eBay for four bucks look how cool
that is first thing I'm going to do is
strip this lacquer and paint off the
handle
one hour later
[Music]
it's like that
[Music]
now I just need to get a sheath for it
there's two ways to make a sheath either
you can sew it and that's all the tools
you need or you can use rivets and
that's all you need both sets of tools
only cost a few bucks
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
now that is it actually be proud to go
camping with a couple hours of work and
a little bit of elbow grease this four
dollar ax has become something to
cherish forever
all right Mimi what's the manliest
Bushcraft project we can do
so Flint Strikers that little piece of
Steel that you smack against Flint in
order to make fire we're gonna make one
from this piece of a car suspension this
is leaf spring steel you guys ready yeah
It's Hammer Time hey so guys right there
yeah again now you're gonna hit it right
there we're gonna put it get it back up
[Applause]
foreign
in order for a flint Striker to make a
spark it has to be hardened high carbon
steel so you take this leaf spring steel
and you heat it up until it's a bright
orange and you dunk it quickly in water
and that'll make it hard enough to make
a spark and you can either do that in a
forge in a campfire or with a torch
[Music]
one of the things I hope you're taking
away from these videos is that these
projects are super easy and don't
require a lot of specialty tools and in
that Spirit I'm going to show you how to
make a flint Striker without needing a
blacksmithing Forge just an angle
grinder we're gonna take another little
piece of car spring steel and instead of
beating it into shape we're going to cut
it into shape really easy
that looks real good doesn't it foreign
there we go only took about an hour and
a half and I made a flint Striker from
an angle grinder and a torch
well there we go two flint Strikers one
I made in a forge one I made without a
forge
the Flint Striker you gots to make a
Tinder Box let's get some jute or hemp
rope unravel it
all right that right there is one of the
best fire tenders you can get it's
awesome now if you're a little bit lazy
and you don't want to unpick this I'll
show you a quick way to do it
foreign
super fine Tinder this stuff burns like
crazy the way you make fire with this
Flint Strikers you take a little spark
and you put it onto a bit of charred
cloth so we need to make some char cloth
so just get yourself a little metal box
then get yourself a piece of linen I
find old dress shirts work really well
I've got a lot of them laying around
since they don't practice the law
anymore now seal that up tight if you
got some hot coals from a campfire you
can put the box right on that and it
works really well if you want to see
lots of smoke coming out of the box that
means the cloth is charring blowtorch
works well too
you see we got a nice black color there
but still not quite done in the middle
we'll give it just like a minute extra
oh yeah that looks good when it's
perfect it should break apart really
easy but you don't want it so done that
it turns to dust put a little char cloth
right there
right there see that lember put that
char cloth in there
whoo
and there you go fire it's gonna take a
little metal tin
put in our char cloth put in a little
piece of flint like this
there's your fire starting kit right
there
you know what they say the best part of
camping is the food and if you want to
get your cholesterol way up there then
you're gonna need your own camping
griddle we're gonna make one we got a
plain piece of 22 gauge weldable steel
from the hardware store no galvanization
on it
next you're gonna need a ball peen
hammer and a hard surface I've got an
anvil but you can use a piece of
concrete a rock whatever you got you're
just gonna hold it at a 45 degree angle
and beat it about a half inch into the
metal
all right you got a little bit of a a
bow to the metal oh
there we go we've peeing the outside of
the sheet metal created a little bit of
a lip and it's made the metal really
strong so it doesn't flex and bend as
much you could use this same technique
to kind of spiral in further further and
further and make yourself like a wok or
a steel bowl
[Applause]
foreign
got this little pin in here now we're
going to smush it
and get my finger in the process
there's one handle on
having handles isn't completely
necessary and almost half the weight of
this griddle is in the handle so if you
want you can just leave the handles off
all right I'm going to burn off this
label and give the griddle a non-stick
surface
when you heat up the pan it gets this
metallicky blue finish on it that's
called bluing the metal and that helps
make it a little bit more corrosion
resistant we're going to go ahead and
blue all the metal here
all right for the next step I need to
take it in my wife's kitchen you love it
when I do Bushcraft projects in your
kitchen right love
it we're gonna create a non-stick
coating on this griddle by seasoning it
just like you would cast iron so I'm
going to season at 375. I'm just going
to coat this pan in a light coating of
olive oil and we're gonna do the whole
pan because sometimes food gets on the
handles and it also protects it from
rust
my griddle's been in the oven for like
eight hours and just every 45 minutes or
so I've been coating it in olive oil so
let's check it out and see where it's at
that is looking great but there's a
little bit of roughness from where the
seasoning went on uneven so I'm gonna
hit it just with a little bit of
sandpaper and that should make it as
slick as can be
[Music]
there you go smooth as silk and ready to
cook
if you're going to be using leaves as
toilet paper might as well drink from an
animal skin as well oh yeah we're making
a water skin
foreign
got a nice piece of beeswax and I'm
gonna mind it
if you don't have a heat gun you can
just melt the beeswax on the stove top
and use your wife's hair dryer that
works too you want the leather to soak
up as much beeswax as it can and the
beeswax will start to soak through on
the outside you just don't want to have
puddles in the bottom
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
really
there we go
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there you go two liter water flask not
bad and absolutely no leaks now you may
not think it but a spoon is a very
useful tool what did you
do oh you could make a spoon using a
hook knife and a piece of wood
and I've done that but it's much easier
quicker and better to make it from
cowhorn
put that horn in there for about 15
minutes see what happens
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
all right just bend it up a little bit
get the shape I like we'll finish
polishing it
one thing that's fun about horn is it's
it's not as brittle as you think it is
it's got a lot of Bend to it you can put
this in your back pocket and
accidentally sit on it and probably be
okay really flexible cleaning it off
with a little bit of olive oil there
well there we go beautiful cow horn
spoon
and if you polish it really good and
clean it off it doesn't taste like cow
horn so that's good all right
do you like stabbing things I know I do
so let's make some custom knives it's
cheap and easy now if you want you can
build your own Forge and do it from
scratch and I've got a video on how to
do that but if your wife doesn't want
you monopolizing the driveway with your
blacksmithing Forge there's a solution
for that problem too I've got it in my
hand two knife flakes yeah most knife
making companies will sell blanks and
then you can customize and put your own
handle on it make your own sheath and
you'll have a super awesome high quality
customized knife so Maura is a really
well-known Swedish bushcrafting Knife
Company and uh this Mora number two
knife blank was only eleven dollars or
if you have a little bit more a taste
for the Exotic check out this jelly roll
Damascus steel Japanese Tonto knife
blank mmm
this is only 20 bucks but both of these
knives require two very different types
of handles and I'm going to show you how
to do both all right let's start with
this mora knife and you can see the Tang
is flat and it's kind of funky shape I
think this is a piece of coca-bola I
found it my scrap wood pile here and
I'll need a 3 16 drill bit for this
portion of the tang and you see it's
going to need to be a little bit longer
than the typical drill bit that little
edge of the piece of tape tells me how
deep I want to go
now we're going to use a 5 16 drill bit
to drill out this portion
all right so now we got a little bit of
a tricky spot we got this flared neck
here I'm going to take this 1 8 inch
piece of Steel and cut out a little
pattern that exactly matches the neck of
this tank
there you go I made the tip almost an
exact replica this part of the knife
I've got the leftover horn from my horn
mug project we're gonna chop the tip off
and use that in our knife handle
foreign
foreign
a half and a couple screw-ups later I
finally did it right
now if you want you can burn the end of
the wood
shove the blade in all the way it'll
lock in there really good you've got a
perfectly good knife handle but you'll
have these little gaps on the side of
the blade the whole purpose of burning
this horn collar is that then you get a
nice square fit that's flush up against
the blade it's just Aesthetics
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
off with like a 60 grit sandpaper and I
slowly worked my way up to a 2000 grit
sandpaper I'm gonna try to milk the last
little bit of linseed oil out of this
can
that looks pretty good doesn't it and I
thought this was coca-bola but I'm not
so sure now that I got it polished up
we'll keep putting linseed oil on it
until it won't take no more
and if you've done your job right the
knife really shouldn't need hardly any
glue should be really sturdy and stable
all on its own no wiggle in that at all
the glue is just kind of a formality
there we go that looks pretty nice
all right we'll let that leather dry all
right leather's all dried so they got a
nice shape to it
oh it's raining I get my step foot away
I'm behind linseed oil
we rubbed it in oil now we're gonna
impregnate it with beeswax
now that right there
is a knife I take camping
look at that
yeah that is nice I really like that
now I'm going to show you how to put a
handle on this type of knife something
with a full flat Tang
foreign you like that better way better
all right
there we go
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to drill through these little holes here
and we're gonna put these rivets in so
I've got a 1 8 inch drill bit and a 1 8
inch brass Rod slowly and carefully
after very low pressure
gonna flip that around do that with our
other piece here
when you hit these little brass rods
they squish and mushroom at the tops and
it forms a Fastener it rivets the handle
onto the tank and that's really what
keeps the handle on not the glue
foreign
I ran out of linseed oil so I'm using
olive oil
an African mahogany looks pretty doesn't
it
really basic simple
handle and sheath
a lot of different ways to do this
hey Becca I made the knife
all right guys now we're gonna make a
canteen
from a water buffalo horn now you can
use any Hollow horn Ram's Horn cow horn
buffalo horn but you know it's a water
buffalo it's got the word water in the
name just get them off eBay or off your
local cows and clean them out so they
don't smell funky inside
hmm you want to find out where the
hollow spot begins so get a little piece
of baling wire push it up there until
you find the end here
now we need to plug the back end and we
can do it just like we did with the horn
mug and try to shape a piece of wood
exactly the same then epoxy it in but
I've got a little shortcut you can use
and this shortcut will also work on the
horn mug project if you want it to
a little bit of cardboard
oh we got a lot of resin leaking out
what I should have done is used a little
wood glue to glue the cardboard to the
bottom of the water buffalo horn and
once it was dried then add the resin but
you know live and learn
resin's all dried
well there we go let's see if it holds
water
don't see any drips yeah I think it
works
corn canteen what do you think look at
me I'm fashionable and hydrated
um
doesn't taste like Buffalo that's good
hmm another awesome project you could
knock out on a Saturday Nathan what do
you want to make
home the strike fell into the heart of
my enemies not exactly
a project but it's manly right yeah
take the Sandpaper and you need to sand
it until it's all smooth 10 seconds
later
nice and smooth
you don't really need to put a layer of
epoxy on this but because I'm giving it
to Nathan I think a little extra
protection might help
now the epoxy's dry we're gonna put a
strap on this thing
Nathan I got something for you
there you go
every good young Viking boy needs a war
horn well I think that's all the
projects I can cram into this strange
yet informative video if you want to see
me actually use the equipment I made
today out in the bush in a real camping
trip then make sure to click subscribe
and stay tuned because we'll be putting
that video out shortly I'll see you next
Saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]